se preparan las mesas de negociación con
miras a reactivar el acuerdo nuclear
iraní- el jefe de política exterior de
la unión europea josep borrell anunció
que las delegaciones se reunirán el 29
de noviembre según confirmó poco después
el jefe negociador de irán ali bagheri
quien espera así trazar camino para el
levantamiento de las sanciones impuestas
a su país representantes de eeuu irán
gran bretaña china francia
alemania y rusia se reunirán en el
encuentro que será presidido por enrique
mora jefe de gabinete de josep borrell
una decisión acogida con beneplácito por
eeuu que indicó que está dispuesto a
volver a unirse al acuerdo se irán lo
dice en serio de su windows esta ventana
de oportunidad no estará abierta para
siempre especialmente si irán continúa
tomando medidas nucleares proactivas
junto con el organismo internacional de
energía atómica hemos expresado nuestra
preocupación por varias de esas medidas
en los últimos días así que ciertamente
esperamos que cuando la delegación iraní
regrese a viena a finales de este mes lo
haga dispuesta a negociar
cuando dejó el acuerdo entonces 18 el
expresidente de eeuu donald trump volvió
a imponer sanciones al país lo que llevó
a teherán a acelerar una vez más su
programa nuclear las discusiones
recientes se estancaron después de la
elección en junio del presidente de
línea dura de iraní ebrahim raisi y se
espera un notorio acercamiento cuando
las conversaciones finalmente se
reanuden en viena